Jarosław 'pashaBiceps' Jarząbkowski was
born on April 11th, 1988 and grew up in Nasielsk,
Poland — a village an hour away from Warsaw.
The town was small and didn’t have many
things to do, so when an internet cafe opened
up nearby, pasha and his friends jumped at
the opportunity to pass the time playing video
games.
From this humble start, pasha stands today
as not only one of the most celebrated players
in the world, but also one of the most successful.
He is a beloved community figure and a role
model for a generation of Counter-Strike fans.
This is his story.
After discovering Counter-Strike 1.6, pasha
quickly became the best player in his town.
He began to play in tournaments and invested
plenty of time into the game, further growing
his skills.
However, his passion wasn’t enough to put
bread on the table — especially considering
that by the end of high school he was already
seriously committed to his future wife, Kinga
The scene was simply not yet big enough to
play Counter-Strike full-time, so pasha made
ends meet by working construction jobs.
When Kinga found work in the big city of Warsaw,
the pair moved there, but quickly found it
difficult to cope with the increased cost
of living.
Pasha tried to study physical therapy, but
left his education after half a year — the
lure of Counter-Strike was too strong, and
he wasn’t ready to give up on his dream
of playing professionally.
With Kinga at his side, pasha decided to make
a gamble and play Counter-Strike full-time,
promising her that someday the risk would
be worth it.
Pasha devoted himself to the game and year
after year he made more and more money.
He gained the attention of some of Poland’s
greatest CS players, collectively known as
“The Golden Five”, including TaZ, NEO,
Loord and kuben.
This already legendary group recruited pasha
into their ranks, launching his career to
the next level.
Alongside those players, pasha’s dream began
to become a reality.
For the next few years, pasha and his Polish
brethren were an elite force in the CS 1.6
scene — especially in 2011.
The Poles were threats at any event they attended,
and continued to perform all the way until
the switch to Counter-Strike: Global Offensive
in late 2012.
But, the change in version wasn’t easy.
Pasha and the team were still top-tier competitors,
but their performance fluctuated dramatically
throughout the back half of 2012 and early
2013.
While they had a number of Top 4 finishes,
they placed badly just as often.
Despite sticking together for many years,
it was time for a change, and so Loord and
kuben would leave the team in the later half
of 2013.
During this difficult time, pasha and Kinga
were married.
This big step cast doubt into pasha’s mind,
and he questioned whether or not he should
leave Counter-Strike behind for a more “normal”
job.
His teammates NEO and TaZ talked him into
sticking with the team, predicting that the
scene would grow and he would be able to support
his wife by playing.
With the empty slots on the roster filled
with the young talents of Snax and byali,
pasha continued to chase his dream.
Unfortunately, at the first CS:GO Major, DreamHack
Winter 2013, the new roster got off to a slow
start, failing to make it out of the group
stage.
Inconsistency, it seemed, was their consistency,
a trend that holds true to this day.
Some days, the team were an unstoppable juggernaut, and other days they were limp and listless,
(Commentators Casting)
Thankfully, they wasted no time in bouncing
back, and in front of their hometown Polish
crowd, won the next major, ESL One Katowice
2014, just five months later.
The win heralded a period of strength and one
of their best years to date, and in 2014 they
had 14 Top-4 finishes at significant events.
In-game, pasha found a home on the AWP, but
he also cemented himself as a flexible player
with unshakeable calm and experience to boot,
deadly in any situation.
With his professional career an in-game skills
reaching new heights, pasha’s profile out
of game was also skyrocketing.
His open personality and immensely popular
stream helped the world see that he is far
from your stereotypical gamer.
He is a family man and an avid gym-goer, the
origin of the muscular moniker in his name.
He earned respect for his friendly ways,
his passion for the game, his unwavering dedication
and love for his wife and newborn child.
This combination of his deadly in-game play
and his genuine personality gained pasha a
very special spot in the hearts of the CS
community.
He was becoming more than just another player.
As the calendar turned to 2015, the inconsistent Virtus.pro returned.
But they still had some highlights - classic Virtus.pro.
(Commentators Casting)
Their nine Top-4 finishes at premiere events
between March and July, including the semifinals
exits at the Majors in Katowice and Cologne,
were balanced by 5 placings of 5-6th or worse
at premiere events during the same time period.
For much of the fall Virtus.pro played extremely
well, but a disappointing loss in the quarterfinals
of the DreamHack Cluj-Napoca Major was the
start of a slump by the Poles’ incredibly
high standards.
Between October 2015 and May 2016 they bombed
out of the ESL ESEA Pro League Season 2, IEM
San Jose, DreamHack Leipzig, the IEM Masters
World Championship and DreamHack Masters Malmo
to add to another quarterfinal exit at the
MLG Major Championship: Columbus.
(Commentators Casting)
There were issues in shotcalling and play.
However, the team did what they have always
done best: stick it out through thick and thin.
Loyalty had always defined the Poles, and
here it shone through — although the community
speculated about a potential split, Virtus.pro
fought through it all.
A resurgence halfway through the year at the
ESL One Cologne Major followed by trophies
at ELEAGUE Season 1,
DreamHack Bucharest 2016,
DreamHack Masters Las Vegas 2017 and a hard-fought
second place at the ELEAGUE Major 2017 had
returned the team to their rightful place
as one of the elite teams in all of CS:GO.
While they famously still struggle online,
no one dares mess with Virtus.pro on LAN.
(Commentators Casting)
As for pashaBiceps, he shows no sign of slowing down.
Now 29 years old, older than most esport athletes,
his stream is more popular than ever and his
team is performing at the top level.
While he dreams of some day opening a gym
or an esports academy of sorts in his native
Poland, for now the ride isn’t over just yet.
Oh, and that promise he made to his wife all
those years ago?
With more than 500,000 US dollars in prize
winnings (not to mention his impressive salary),
it’s safe to say he kept his word.
Despite the struggles, pasha never doubted
in his team, his commitment to his family
or his dream, and it paid off.
He truly is pashaBiceps.